NOW, HERE TO PROVIDE INSIGHT
INTO OBAMA'S CAREFREE, I COULD
GIVE A (BLEEP) BECAUSE I AM
ABOUT TO LEAVE THIS JOB ATTITUDE
IS AN EXPERT ON WALKING AWAY
FROM THE JOB BEFORE IT'S DONE
AND PHONING IT IN UNTIL THE END,
OUR SENIOR BLACK CORRESPONDENT
JON STEWART.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
>> JON STEWART.
>> SO HOW YOU DOING?
>> LISTEN, I AM DOING VERY WELL
BUT YOU KNOW I AM NOT BLACK.
YOU KNOW, I AM NOT BLACK.
>> I AM NOT BLACK.
>> I JUST WANTED TO LET YOU FEEL
HOW UNCOMFORTABLE BEING ON
SOMEBODY ELSE'S SHOW IS AND
HAVING AN ENTIRE RACE ON YOUR
SHOULDERS.
>> I DO THAT.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU DID THAT.
>> IT IS VERY UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> I AM JUST (BLEEP)ING WITH
YOU, MAN.
NO, YOU ARE REALLY HERE AS OUR
SENIOR DON'T GIVE A (BLEEP)
ANYMORE CORRESPONDENT.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Larry: SO GIVE US A SENSE
OF HOW OBAMA MAY REACT AS HE
HEADS INTO HIS FINAL STRETCH.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, LARRY --
>> WHY WOULD YOU EVEN THINK
THAT'S HOW I AM -- DO YOU HAVE
ANY CHIPS OR DIPS AROUND HERE OR
ANYTHING?  DO YOU HAVE ANY POT
OR --
>> YOU KNOW YOU ARE ALREADY
HIGH, JON.
SERIOUSLY, JON, YOU ARE NOT EVEN
TRYING ANYMORE, ARE YOU?  I MEAN
LAST NIGHT YOU DID LIKE AN
ENTIRE SEGMENT WHERE YOU DIDN'T
EVEN TALK.
[MAKING NOISES]
>> SO, WHAT? YOU DON'T HAVE A
SCRIPT ANYMORE, WHAT IS GOING
ON?
>> WE DO HAVE SCRIPTS, WE DO.
WE DO HAVE SCRIPTS.
THERE IS SOMETHING I NEVER TOLD
YOU, LARRY.
I CAN'T READ.
>> Larry: I DID NOT KNOW THAT.
>> AN EXCLUSIVE RIGHT HERE.
>> OKAY, HERE IS ONE, OBAMA
CALLS YOU DOWN TO THE WHITE
HOUSE TWICE FOR SECRET MEETINGS;
IS THAT TRUE?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THEY WERE
SECRET.
I MEAN I AM IN THE VISITORS LOG
AND THEY TOOK PICTURES OF THE
MEETING.
AND --
>> WHAT DID HE WANT?
>> WHAT DID HE WANT.
TO HANG OUT.
EAT NACHOS.
WATCH "KING RALPH".
>> Larry: THE JON GOODMAN
MOVIE WHERE HE BECOMES KING OF
ENGLAND?
>> DON'T PRETEND LIKE YOU
HAVEN'T SEEN "KING RALPH".
I KNOW YOU HAVE SEEN IT.
>> Larry: I KNOW, I KNOW.
I WATCH IT ONCE EVERY MONTH.
YOU GUYS JUST WATCHED MOVIE AND
TALKED (BLEEP).
>> NOT JUST A MOVIE.
KING RALPH.
BOTH VISITS.
GOT IT.
>> SO YOU THINK HE WAS TRYING TO
INFLUENCE YOU AND THE JOKES YOU
MAKE?  THAT IS A LITTLE
DANGEROUS, ISN'T THAT A LITTLE
IRRESPONSIBLE?
>> NO, I THINK THAT'S WHAT HE IS
TRYING TO DO BECAUSE I HAVE A
TELEVISION SHOW AND SOMETIMES WE
SAY (BLEEP) ABOUT HIM AND HIS
POLICIES SO I AM PRETTY SURE I
WAS THERE BECAUSE HE HAS RUN OUT
OF PEOPLE TO WATCH "KING RALPH"
WITH.
SO LET ME GET YOUR HONEST
OPINION, DO YOU THINK OBAMA IS
IN DO NOT CARE MODE.
>> , NO I THINK HE IS I AM GOING
TO BUILD ME A LIBRARY WITH MY
NAME ON IT MODE.
>> Larry: WOW.
WHAT ABOUT YOU?  WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO DO.
>>
>> WHAT IS THAT?
>> Larry: WHAT ARE YOU GOING
TO DO.
>> AFTER I LEAVE THE SHOW.
>> Larry: YES WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO DO?
>> I AM DOING IT RIGHT NOW.